40% of all jobs they project in the next
10 years are going to disappear because
of technology it's gonna be replaced by
an algorithm it's gonna be changed you
know all these guys on Wall Street
you're seeing all these algorithms take
over and they're getting rid of all
these traders there's nothing unique
about your thoughts they've been around
for thousands of years you're just
tapping into the because of what you're
doing with your body that makes you too
fearful or passionate or courageous or
whatever you're feeling as you go in
those states you get different thoughts
I always tell people knowledge is not
power it's total BS knowledge is
potential power execution Trump's
knowledge every day of the week and some
of my life is how do you get yourself to
execute need motivation watch a top 10
with believe nation what's that belief
nation at seven my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
growing up in a chaotic and abusive
household leaving home at 17 and being a
janitor to becoming one of the most
recognized and successful coaches
speakers and motivators in the world
he's Tony Robbins and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success volume for
joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one retool yourself I always tell people
the most valuable lesson I got from my
mentor Jim Rohn was I asked my father
worked two jobs
we were always broke we had no money for
food and we lived in a community we
moved to it's just I thought they were
all rich and we're on the other side of
the tracks it was a lower middle class
but compared to where we lived before
these people seemed rich compared to us
and I just didn't understand it and Jim
said to me Tony it's not about the value
of your soul it's about the value of you
and the marketplace and your father's
skills are not that valuable he used to
take he was underground parking
attendant and he would take people's
ticket and make change well the research
now shows is being done at Yale's being
done overseas in England as well and
they found that 40 percent of all jobs
they project in the next 10 years are
going to disappear because of technology
it's gonna be replaced by an algorithm
it's gonna be changed you know all these
guys on Wall Street you're seeing all
these algorithms take over and they're
getting rid of all these traders right
it's changing radically these in these
hedge funds there's 3 million truck
drivers self-driving cars are here in
the next five years they will be the
standard certainly within seven or eight
years are you gonna hire someone who can
only work eight hours a day and
sometimes gets drunk or can make a
mistake when you can buy a machine write
down the Machine and be in a position
where it works 24 hours a day driving
but no one is telling these drivers this
and it's they have to retool now so
technology is the biggest challenge
labor is less valuable because of
efficiencies with technology and it's
gonna get that are in better for
technology which is scary when you think
about what's gonna happen for jobs so I
say to people you got to participate in
your own rescue
you've got to retool yourself the idea
of the Bernie Sanders has of providing
free education it sounds wonderful but
the education he wants to do is
Community College there are no skill
sets in Community College's today for
the most part that are gonna prepare you
for the economy or a job that's there so
what is that gonna do you're just going
to waste more money more time we need to
retool ourselves the government's not
gonna do it for you
rule number two discipline your mind
these thoughts we have we
think there are thoughts or makes it
really hard to change them people
meditate try to not think possible show
me somebody found that successfully
consistently the potion hey everybody
the mind thinks thoughts but here's the
distinction if I told you 100 years ago
we're gonna fly the moon and back you
would call me a lunatic that's where the
term comes from people still use it it
doesn't make any sense because a lunatic
is somebody thought we owe the moon back
we've done it right I didn't know that
but if I would have told you 100 years
ago that there's gonna be a box in your
pocket and you're gonna pull this thing
out you're gonna hit a couple buttons
and then it's gonna capture invisible
waves that are drifting around the earth
and bring the waves in and you're gonna
see somebody on the other side of the
earth and you're gonna talk to them
you're totally nuts thoughts are those
invisible waves and when you use your
body in a certain way if I sit like this
I'm gonna channel I'm gonna tap into a
different channel those waves than if
I'm sitting like this kind of like a TV
set if I turn one channel might be a
comedy channel I'm gonna see a lot of
laughter turn another one it's a horror
channel turn another channel it's a
romance channel this is what changes
which of those waves you touch in so if
you can start to realize that your
thoughts do you think are your thoughts
there's nothing unique about your
thoughts they've been around for
thousands of years you're just tapping
into the because of what you're doing
with your body that makes you too
fearful or passion or too courageous or
whatever you're feeling as you go in
those states you get different thoughts
so what I want people to see is that
learn how to just see those thoughts go
by learn how to be entertained by those
thoughts because I have crazy thoughts
then but what I've got good at is going
look at that crazy thought That's not me
that's the mind not your mind cuz if
it's you how do you change you pretty
hard but I really truly know there's I
haven't heard a thought come out of you
that's original you've called them your
thoughts but they're not you've stolen
them they've been around forever when
you see that it's easier to let go of
them and letting go of those thoughts is
one of the ways that you free yourself
and then again the more you do it just
like a muscle you get better and better
better than all of a sudden they used to
make you crazy or stressed out or make
how many things you'd be worried about
then never came to be and some people
their life is good so they worry about
other people
they're never not worried right so it's
really just a pattern if you want wealth
real wealth is not just money it's
emotion that's like what are we really
after in money you know on money you
want piece of the paper with these
pictures of deceased notables on it you
want we think money will give you think
it'll give you freedom or security or
stability or love it won't give you love
it'll get you sex it won't get you love
right so really what you're after is the
emotion and so what I want people to get
is the emotion they want down and all it
is is a new habit it's learning to
discipline this mind right by realizing
the main thoughts are out there and
letting them float by and constantly
coming back to what can I love about
this what can I appreciate it's like if
you can learn to love or at least
appreciate start to enjoy the things
that you used to get upset about how
much freedom would you have how much
more joy to have and I know people got
billions of dollars I've coached them
who was like holy Sh they live in
scarcity all the time when man I'll
never forget he's screaming at his wife
I'm in the meat I mean I'm in the house
and he's screaming his wife because she
spent some money on a bunch of outfits
and stuff like that he's a
multi-billionaire he couldn't spend all
his money in his lifetime and then he's
totally upset at his daughters in her
20s who spent some money too and I'm
like I pulled almost afterwards and I
said what do you do this for and what do
you do it for it he's like well it's
just it's the principle thing I said no
the principle thing is do you love these
people and do you want them to have an
abundant wife when you have you don't
have one loss but you live like you're
poor you know it's like I finally got
through to them but so many people
that's why I say money doesn't change
you money magnifies who you are so you
want to expand the depth of who you are
and free yourself from suffering by just
knowing it's a pattern of thought and
you can change the pattern of thought
rule number three learn to execute I
know you get on an airplane what's the
first thing they say if we get into
trouble masks will come down oxygens
there and the first thing you got to do
is put it on your kid right no why
they literally tell you to put it on
yourself you selfish bastard what's the
deal here right but it's because we
don't take care of ourselves we can't
tear them so for leaders when I was
telling this it's you first it starts
with you and it starts with your
psychology 80% of growing a business if
you look at what the choke hold is on
our business
it's always the leader and 80% of that
chokehold is the psychology at 20% the
mechanics I mean people in this room
know the mechanics and strategy is
beyond what anybody on earth knows in
their category so it's really about you
being in the state where you execute
it's like I always tell people knowledge
is not power it's total BS knowledge is
potential power execution Trump's
knowledge every day of the week and some
of my life is how do you get to yourself
to execute an execution comes from
learning to put yourself in that right
state of it it rule number four master
the skill of influence I believe that
leadership is really a skill of
influence it is the most important skill
that any human being can master and I
don't think of leadership as a position
I see it as a skill a tool that all of
us have to have in other words the
quality of your life either really
believe comes down to your level of
leadership other people don't have to
follow you to be a leader but you have
to live life on your terms and the first
person you have to influence it yourself
you know whether you're fit or fat you
know whether your kids are out you know
on drugs or not it's who has more
influence the guy in the street corner
or you with your fitter fat is can you
influence your own hands your own body
your own mind to do what's necessary so
I think to be able to influence the
thoughts the feelings the emotions and
the actions of another human being
that's what leadership is rule number
five build work-life integration
I believe in work-life integration I
don't think and I might be disrespectful
- oh no no yeah I'm saying everybody has
a different metaphor I'm telling my
metaphor I'm not making somebody wrong
focus my balance but to me if you say
balance it's like okay let's use a
teeter totter or a seesaw okay we're
gonna let's balance it now now that
we've done that how long are we gonna
stay in there balancing this thing
before one of us wants to jerk this
thing around just to feel alive right
yeah so I really think balance is is
more about integration for me it's more
about like how do I make sure that I
feel like the errors of my life my wife
my children my grandchildren my health
sports
I got 31 companies I got 1,200 employees
and seven radically different industries
we do five billion a year
I mean it's so all these things are
going on
how do I do that well I believe that the
way I do that is the streaks that he
streaks of unbelievable intensity work
and I just reeks of like let go and
being you know paradise and enjoy and so
I like running hot I wanna I wanna at
the end have the climb in the amount
that's just me so I'm not singing that
track for other people I'm saying gotta
find what it is but the idea of balance
for most people makes them torture
themselves and I say it for me
it did tortures you get rid of it and
instead of saying talk about innovation
I asked Mary Callahan Erdos who's if
you're not familiar with her she's
probably the one of it's not the
smartest person in the financial boil
female she's had a JP Morgan and manages
2.3 trillion with a team how to be
trillion dollars with the money well the
nicest human beings over me breaks all
the moles on people in the financial
business there's not an ounce of
manipulation in her body I mean just
good good soul and I asked her about the
balance thing the biggest bank in the
world right trillions of dollars and she
said Tony I don't believe in it and she
told me were concise don't laugh or
complete each other's sentences she has
the same philosophy but her dad used to
take her to work and he was a financial
guy when she was a little girl she has
never brother be the secretary if the
she took her dad see Iran Michelle and
she said doing that with my dad she goes
I loved it I was a part of his life I
got to be a part of see that part of his
life instead of coming home and me not
knowing it and she said that's what
she's done with her kids in a JP Morgan
she leaves and picks her kids up and she
still runs the biggest thing the world
goes trillions of dollars so when she
say it's found she'd say no it's not
bounce it's integrate she knows when to
move into one or the
right so that all the parts of her life
are rich maybe instead of balance it's a
rich life in the areas that matter yeah
right rich with your children rich with
your husband or wife rich with your dear
friends rich with the impact that you
want to have your mission rich in terms
of successful business and or whatever
your career is that you really feel a
sense of meaning and enjoyment to me
that's more important than balance and I
think but I'm a very passionate balance
a little boring
if you're tortured by balance trying to
be balanced by um people hard not
balanced enough instead enjoy yourself
enjoy your children enjoy the time be
where you are right now that to me is
more important trying to make everything
balance because that becomes negative
cerebral it makes you evaluate things a
more you evaluate the less you can
actually experience what's here right
now
rule number six give energy everything
in my world is based on coming up with
the outcome that will serve and then
going at it but most the time your
approach going at it doesn't work no one
else knows that but you know you can see
it doesn't work so it's constantly
changing your approach until you can get
where you want to go and I enter an
audience and I'm gonna give a talk of
any sort I do a huge amount of homework
in advance I prepare as he is there but
then when I stand up here I wouldn't be
sitting like this I'm scanning
constantly who I'm looking for the
people think it's bull I'm going to have
the people who got dragged there I'm not
looking for the people clapping for me
you know that those people will always
be there and there's some people clap
even if you're terrible so you don't
want to other people's view make you
feel good I'm looking for who isn't
there so that I can reach them so I can
show them that there's something real
here because you know most people don't
know who I am they'd see you know ten
thousand people jumping in a stadium and
they go it's just a big motivational
pump up I've never been a motivator it's
never open up what I've been about I
think motivation is useful is like a
warm bath you should probably take a
bath or a shower every day but you need
more than that you need strategy and but
what I really believe is the energy most
of us grew up and right now most of you
are learning and the traditional style
you did leave when you're in school you
were trained to go to your seat and be
silent and be polite and nice but the
world we live in today isn't like that
the world today if somebody sits down
and waits for someone tell them what to
do they're in trouble so my approach is
constantly stimulating and seeing
it's real getting people to be raw and
getting to truth you know corny as it is
the truth sets us free and we all can
find our own truth as long as we put
ourselves an environment where we don't
tolerate anything less than that rule
number seven my personal favorite learn
how to lead I really believe in order to
influence people you got to know what
already influences them huh the mistake
that we make is we don't connect enough
to figure out who this person is and
what most of us do is try to lead other
people by influencing them the way we'd
be influenced they try to influence
their kid to clean the room the way that
would make you do it but even though
they're your kid they're different than
you and so they're gonna do it for a
different set of reasons than what you
would do it for you might have done it
because someone told you to but your
kids come all day long that's not it
there has to be something else it's a
sense of freedom they get from it or a
sense of mass just something that's
gonna move them so I always say there
there are two things that influence
everyone if you want to be a leader you
have to know how to change other
people's States a person is in a no
state a person's in an angry state
persons in a frustrated state you have
to be able to influence their stake is
if you change their state you're gonna
change the result they get but the
second thing you have to understand is
what are people's blueprints blueprints
my shorthand for what are the values
what do they believe what do they fear I
always say to people that life is found
in the dance between what you desire
most and what you fear most if I want to
lead you and support you I got to know
your goals your desires I don't know
what you're scared about what you're
fearful about what stresses you out and
if I understand that I can communicate
in a way that will inspire you to
maximize not only when I'm here that's
management leadership is ungodly ways
your own standard and you're gonna
continue to perform at a higher level
rule number eight change your story how
to do something is the wrong sequence to
start with like what's the strategy for
being fit and healthy it's not that
complex and yet 70% of the u.s. is
overweight he doesn't have to do it it's
not a strategy problem but it is is why
are they doing it it's because they have
a story and everyone does is
entrepreneurs business people everyone
does this when we get fearful when we've
tried something that we're not
succeeding as fast as we want when we
are afraid of failing we
but with a story about how it's not our
fault or how we're gonna do it in the
future because they would not have to
feel bad feeling bad makes us have to
deal with it most people are overwhelmed
so they just they come up with a story
that I tried everything
have you tried everything you'd be fit
you know I tried million six millions
name of three things they did any times
that don't work but I think if you can
come up when you change the story when
you come up with a new set of beliefs
you'll find yourself finding the
strategy or using the strategies that
already worked in there that right now
your mind says are won't work and the
best way to change people you got
strategy story is state and I only share
this with distance owners you've got to
be able to produce a different state of
your people there has to be something
compelling there has to be a sense of
mission rule number nine get feedback
how do you get better how do you know
listen I was good today but I want to be
great what are the metrics you use I
mean is there data you get back how do
you improve well we have all the social
media data which we we use big data to
take a look at but I also look at it
individually because there's nuances
that you pick up in that way so I feed
that look at that but my biggest piece
is watching the audience and then you
know every day in my life I get feedback
and walking down the street a dozen
people come and tell me these beautiful
stories the other life has changed and
very much like like she shared earlier
they'll give me way too much credit so I
always try to go look you did this I'm
glad I got the help and I try to keep
that balance with everybody but my
measurement is both emotional state
impact as well as execution did they
lose 20 pounds did they go turn their
business around you know my business is
organized around I really wanna help
people improve all the qualities the
areas of their life but there's about
seven that matter the most it's your
body it's your emotions that your
relationships it's the way you manage
time its finances it's your work and
it's the spiritual side of life and so
what I spent my life doing is modeling
people that are the best the world you
find a couple have been together for 65
years in their 80s late eighties and
they're still making love and passionate
not just hanging out they're not lucky
they're doing something different so I'm
constantly finding those patterns so
that hopefully I can compress the
decades in today's I can learn from
those decades of life experience say
that bring the answer here to myself and
others and see a immeasurable impact and
rule number 10 the last
for a very special bonus clip is find
happiness and when you're in a negative
state you don't perform at a higher
level when you're in a negative state it
affects your biochemistry affect your
immune system your negative state
affects the people around you when
you're in a great state perform better
enjoy life more greater impact all the
above so it's intelligent to be in a
peace thing but you know you only can
manage what you measure like a business
you know if I want it when I take
company over turn around start measuring
things and I measure the most important
things and the more you measure the
better we'll get because you get more
yet instead of measuring once a year if
you're measuring you know once a week
you got 52 times to improve it versus
one so I started measuring and I said
I'm gonna live in a beautiful state no
matter what every day now in order to do
that I have to do two things
a I have to acknowledge that I've been
suffering and I need to figure out what
my favorite flavor of suffering it and I
and I played off of that with myself and
I thought frustrated and pissed off or
pretty useful for me in fact I realized
that my happiness was so cheap because
all I needed was this thing and I could
lose my happiness because ding something
cool or games something not so cool you
got 1200 poise what are the chances
right now that one of them is doing
something to screw up hey not
consciously they're just not doing what
they're supposed to do basically 100
percent chance and if I was near this I
get triggered my god and my happiness
that disappeared so what it again say is
I want to be happy even if they screw up
I'm gonna be happy in there they lost
the million bucks I want to be happy
like if I happiness is depend upon other
people behaving a certain way the way I
want them to I'm pretty influential guy
but I'm not God hey and everybody's got
their own things that they're doing
I'm never gonna stay happy and if I have
to even make my happiness based on me
behaving a perfect way every mom that's
not gonna happen so I gave room for life
and I decided to make a real decision
that's my invitation to people and that
I'll answer your question hi now first
you got to make the decision that says
life is too short to suffer I mean
I don't know what's gonna happen in your
lifetime with your children with your
wife with your economics your business
I'm sure gonna be well everything but
there's things outside our control the
government could change the rules on
something right the rules have changed
before around direct marketing and so
forth um you're somebody your family
could get very ill someone can die in
our families right no let's talk about
it what could happen if your happiness
is only gonna be what everything matches
how do you think it should be you're not
gonna be there and my view is that
there's power it happens we downplay it
in this culture that when the person is
happy they attract other people when a
person is happy they look longer that's
the back well people are happier they
earn more right they do better in their
careers I mean these are physiological
these are measured facts in our society
and yet we poopoo happen to Center well
my gods being enthusiastic or something
like that
no it's being inspired in spirit healing
oh I so what I did was this is much
energy or passion I had before I still
had that but what I found was what was
the stuff that would suck away that
energy and so now to answer your
question how would I know
number one I put the line lists and and
said these are the ones I tend to drop
into I'm not doing anymore
and if I find it I need a rule I got 90
seconds to get out at 90 second rule
that should have been the for our world
uncertain things everything is easy you
know certainly to get put totally that
was like four out maybe before Dave Ruel
example of initially but as I did it
more and more it's like a muscle and
when you use the muscle over and over
again it works it's their key and so how
I know and an special already discussion
but without that I think people are sad
we're talking about is I sense tension
in my body but when you're in a
beautiful state things flow when there's
a
you can feel at your pace yet somebody
said something somebody is them somebody
didn't do something already use a
certain term somebody you brought
something out or you did something you
should've done whenever that happens
attention and so I'd really train myself
to feel that tension and when I feel
they go 90 seconds and it's a game now
90 seconds and since I value that
happening so much
not like the deluded person I'm so happy
like I value being in a beautiful state
because it may not be happy it may be
driven it may be courageous
it may be feeling bold it may be love it
may be compassion for someone else or
either myself hi Alan I guess I always
have compassion for other people or
never for myself okay and so what I
began to do is realize holy cow this is
something that could change everything
and so that 90 said we're gonna feel the
tension and then here's what I do I know
that it's triggered by one of three
language patterns as a trigger as an
example loss less than ever if you
perceive that something someone you're
counting on they failed to do something
that it failed the sale something say
something or or you fail to do something
or say something you should have then
what happens is that tension starts to
show up because your brain goes I lost
that opportunity I lost this moment I
lost that respect I lost this love I
lost the money I lost whatever you
thought your loss and loss is always an
illusion it was like the next
opportunity
two minutes around the corner you know
it's not that complexity if we look for
it if you find it if we don't live in
the illusion of loss or less of the next
one if you think because he or she did
something that didn't do it you have
less of something you value less love
less joy less excitement last time plus
the energy last economics less respect
you're gonna suffer inside you know some
people suffer by being angry some people
suffer by feeling sad everyone has
different flavors right right you're
gonna suffer and the worst one is never
if you think because she or he did mr.
Donald Trump did something or didn't do
it or Mary Sue or you self to do it and
now you'll
we have that love you'll never have that
respect you'll never have that joy you
ever have that economics what you
believe that stuff then the suffering
stays so the way out of Los West never
is always appreciation or gratitude or
love
now I've got a really special bonus Tony
Robbins clip on how to find your mission
but before that question today I want to
know which of these two rules impacted
you the most learn how to lead or
discipline your mind let me know in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
people say they don't care I think what
they really mean is I don't let it stop
me I've dealt with presidents the
countries that dealt with the top
celebrities everybody cares I care but I
don't care level where I'm gonna modify
me I don't care the level where I'm only
gonna do it to try to please somebody
because I know they'll turn something
positive into a negative there's sodium
fearful whenever people say to me by the
way that I'm skeptical or I'm
pessimistic I said come on let's be
honest you're gutless it doesn't take
any courage to say nothing's gonna work
cuz what you're really saying is I'm
afraid to try cuz what if I get my hopes
up and I'm disappointed what if I try
and I fail and then I look bad so the
hipster approach is yeah I'm just not
giving not giving us a way to have a
terrible life I think you do give it I
think you do care but I think you just
don't let it stop you and I think the
way that gets done is you find a mission
that you value more than your fear many
of us will do things for our children we
would never do for ourselves right I
think that's the beauty of human beings
will do things for people we love even
more than ourselves that's what makes us
human I don't get it every day when I'm
exhausted or tired or burnt out my body
hurts when I don't get up because all
this still so wonderful I get up cuz I
have a mission I have something that
excites may have something that keeps me
up late gets me up early it makes me
feel alive if you tell yourself a story
long enough you start to believe it
don't you believe it act like I am Tulsa
what a whale out of handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I've murdered a
rock into the stone hospitalized a brick
I'm so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 4 days of taking
action for a new habit to stick I've
created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access